hey trip mail today if you're not
familiar with hatred mail here's what
hatred mail is because it's time to make
America hate again Patriot mail written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom all
right like most week's this week's
hatred mail really needs no introduction
so I won't give it one here it is Pakman
stop bring so triggered you're a
disgrace to liberals you cuck I being
hate you David you're the poster boy for
the term seriously take down this Bolton
channel now you are of the bone spurs
losers poor deluded fanboys getting
their fix of your garbage from creep
Pakman who is like a lisp diseased I
don't know whether somebody thinks that
I'm just gonna end the show on their
say-so but it's surprisingly common that
people say David I really want you to
end your show now oh oh you know what I
never considered that yeah now that a
random person on the Internet has
suggested it I will just delete our
YouTube channel and just end the show of
course that's not going to happen
and the lisps list thing is kind of
funny the only place that anyone has
ever accused me of speaking with a lisp
in my entire life is on this program in
hatred mail and of course there'd be
nothing wrong whatsoever if I had a lisp
but the only place in my life where
anyone has even suggested that I have a
lisp is on this program and I think it's
part of it's part of the rampant
homophobia I think that exists in hatred
mail and of course you can turn hatred
mail into something positive we have a
coupon code hey tree at 40 which will
save you 40% off of your membership if
applied at david pakman.com slash
membership